[Musique]
on a un deal je vous rappelle les gars
on a déjà fait cours de latin non jamais
c'était d de pas faire cours si on la
ferme on a 19 de moyenne mais si vous
préférez on peut toujours faire des
interéros
gram je suis très très inquiète pour le
maintien de l'option latin l'année
prochaine c'est chaud patate si on fait
rien j'ai peur que ce soit dead alors je
vous présente monsieur Cania il faut que
vos élèves soient brillants à ce
concours monsieur kan va nous
accompagner pendant toute la durée du
concours c'est qui bouff P m'appeler
rodolp votre classeag
la har poterécole
[Musique]
sorroo on juste compris comison é des
grosses mer tout ça parce que vous avez
laemme de nous faire cours dis Norte
quoi vous avez jamais
fait on va trich la prof c'est vous qui
nous dites de tricher mais c'estororal
ça va pas
non on est vraiment obligé de faire
comprend ce qu'il
dit est-ce que c'est clair pour tout le
monde vous êtes en train de tricher ça
fait pas rire mais c'est pas bien grave
il y a rien de grave pour vous en fait
en fait tout ce qui compte pour vous
c'est de garder votre petit confort de
fonctionnaire bonjourine rodolp je vous
ai envoyé une photo là je su désolé pour
monnorme
[Musique]
on a un de concours à gagner vous
me racontez votre vie là cilingus qui
vient du latin cunus qui veut dire
fourau et du verbe lingo lingueré qui
veut dire lécher lécher exactement tu as
une règle grammaticale ou c'est une
intuition linguistique ça intuition
linguistique
[Musique]
OK